mode qui nous
attendons donc la député de mississauga
brampton sud yves adam avant quand elle
était du côté conservateur et après son
passage chez les libéraux ça a été un
des moments marquants de la semaine sur
la scène fédérale parce que sept députés
torontoise avait toujours défendu très
fidèlement les politiques de stephen
âmes et surtout parce qu'elle est la
conjointe de dimitri soudas ce qui est
l'ancien bras droit du premier ministre
alors yves adam est elle un avantage ou
un boulet pour justin trudeau ce soir
tasha est à toronto bien sûr qu'on sorte
achats enseigne elle est à ottawa et
michel lui et à québec bonsoir à vous
deux soit alors les réactions à cette
défection étaient plutôt négatives en
fait tout le monde a réagi en soit
c'était plutôt contreproductif
qu'est ce qui peut expliquer cette
décision donc de justin trudeau tasha
bon et à coupler des théories ça peut
être soit justin trudeau ne comprend
rien de la politique et pense que c'est
une candidate vedette et tout le monde
va l'accueillir avec des grands bras
ouverts ce que je pense pas le chaos
deuxièmement ils cherchent autre chose
c'est-à-dire peut-être le savoir de son
conjoint de son fiancé comme vous avez
mentionné dimitri soudas sts c'est
vraiment l'explication peut-être la plus
évidente dans la situation bon daniel
c'est quand même une députée très
controversée lancée qu'elle a été chassé
du parti conservateur parce qu'elle
avait le comportement autocratique des
tactiques déloyales un cadeau empoisonné
pour justin trudeau mes cadeaux
empoisonnés peut-être cadeau qu'il s'est
fait lui même une heure à que lui-même à
blâmer pour ce cadeau là c'est lui qui
est allé la chercher celui qui l'a
acceptée c'est lui qui l'a annoncé à son
caucus 15 minutes seulement avant de la
présenter à tout le monde écoutait à eva
adams evans ne sais pas c'est pas
mélanie joly que trudeau courtise aussi
en ce moment je suis pas en train de
vous dire que c'est une imbécile loin de
là elle a fait ses preuves dans le
domaine municipal antho sauf que vous
l'avez dit les conservateurs n'en
voulait plus qu'est ce qu'elle peut
apporter aux libéraux qu'ils n'ont pas
déjà je cherche encore la réponse si les
gens exposés des questions sur le
jugement de justin trudeau à l'intérieur
même du parti libéral on s'en pose
encore weight achat il faisait allusion
michel plusieurs disques eelv adams et
elle apparaît que la grosse prise c'est
au fond son conjoint dimitri soudas ce
qu'est ce que lui donc peut apporter aux
libéraux monsieur soudas ce évidemment
qu'on a bien des choses les stratégies
des choses qui se sont passées au parti
conservateur par exemple je suis
convaincu que plus d'informations que
que vous et moi sur ce qui s'est passé
au moment du dauphin gates il ya toutes
sortes d'éléments et de stratégie aussi
qui serait certainement très utile aux
libéraux maintenant est ce que ces
avantages la compense
le mauvaise impression que que l'arrivée
de madame à dams a certainement causé
écoutez c'est tout le monde sic c'est
pas par principe qu'elles sont embauchés
liberos c'était une progressiste qui
sont de plus en plus mal à l'aise chez
conservateurs on pourrait dire bon vous
voyez c'est la preuve que monsieur
trudeau a réussi à recruter des gens
tout bon mais on sait tous que c'est une
carriériste alors je vois pas beaucoup
ce que ça peut donner monsieur trudeau
je ne vois pas quelle va battre le
ministre des finances c'est bien dans ce
comté laquelle qu'elle veut sur les
affaires de façon générale vous savez
les transfuges n'ont pas la cote c'est
très rare maintenant que quelqu'un qui
est un parti et se faire réélire à
l'élection générale suivante sous une
autre étiquette tâche a quand même
dimitri soudas qui était à plusieurs le
journaliste le connaissent pas ce que
c'était le directeur de communication de
il emmenait assez large et les
conservateurs lycée beaucoup de choses
oui c'était l'ancien directeur du parti
aussi c'est quelqu'un qui est qui a été
ramené par monsieur harper après qu'il
avait quitté le bureau du premier
ministre pour essentiellement je pense
concrétiser
les appuis de monsieur harper il le fait
qu'il allait se présenter pour la
prochaine élection qui était en doute ce
moment là alors glissé on dit en anglais
wayne barnes noble où les corps sont
enterrés et c'est ça vraiment qui je
pense fait frissonner je sais ça j'en ai
parlé à des amis conservateurs les fait
frissonner dans ça crée de l'inquiétude
donc on parle oui certainement parce que
c'est des informations sur soi des
députés les faiblesses les faiblesses de
monsieur est certainement d'affi gates
qui pourrait nuire aux conservateurs
lors des prochaines élections il ya une
consolation il ya une consolation
probablement pour les conservateurs
c'est que aussi longtemps qu'elle va 2
n'aura pas été choisie candidate dimitri
soudas ce va pas dire un mot il veut il
voudrait avoir l'assurance qu'il sera
choisi candidate dans les greens et
green tune la russie compte où elle veut
se présenter à toronto c'est loin d'être
acquis du député provincial qui rentre
au delà a dit je rien savoir d'un jeu
pas la voir là elle pas à faire chez
nous toute position attend donc d'autres
libéraux à toronto ne veulent pas
entendre parler d'elle alors aussi
longtemps qu'elle n'aurait pas été
choisie candidate et c'est loin d'être
certain dimitri soudas ne dira pas un
mot
ouais michel justin trudeau et pourtant
promis de faire de la politique
autrement oui mais je pense qu'on a
réalisé là depuis un bon moment cette
vidéo fait de la politique comme tout le
monde et qu'il l'a fait même souvent de
façon moins moins efficaces que d'autres
alors je pense que danse à cet égard là
la démonstration était faite que
monsieur trudeau est un politicien comme
les autres bonjour pour rejoindre un peu
ce qu est ce qu a dit daniel c'est pas
et des nominations ouverte contient un
peu partout les libéraux on voit ça à
ottawa à vancouver edmonton à montréal
des dénominations qui sont choisis
essentiellement par l'entourage de
monsieur trudeau et monsieur trudeau
lui-même alors c'est la politique bras
de fer et ça va pas bien ici je vous dis
à toronto ça jase beaucoup aussi parmi
les libéraux qui sont fâchés pas
seulement monsieur co mais ceux du
fédéral cette orientation c'est toujours
de faire atterrir un transfuge dans un
comté ou qui lui est étranger il ya une
association il ya des militants il ya la
greffe prend pas toujours mais mais mais
mais là dessus les libéraux le parti
libéral c'est une drôle de bibitte dans
l'histoire du canada le parti libéral
vie pour être au pouvoir et pour être au
pouvoir le parti libéral en ce moment va
avaler toutes les couleuvres qu'il devra
avaler on va fermer les yeux sur le
recrutement dave add-ons à il ya des
gens qui vont parler dans les coulisses
offre deux recrues comme aux amours et
français mais en bout de piste ils se
disent que c'est avec justin trudeau un
peu comme le pq avec pierre karl
péladeau c'est avec justin trudeau qui
ont leur unique sans se reprendre le
pouvoir et ils vont fermer les yeux sur
p des choses et qui concerne les
sceptiques tasha non non et c'est sinon
je suis d'accord et c'est pour ça mais
c'est rude aussi qui peut faire
n'importe quoi parce que c'est à cause
de lui qu'ils ont remonté dans les
sondages alors tu situation un peu
dangereux je pense pour un parti qui
doit essentiellement ce sera formulée
sur plusieurs plans politiques et
organisations mais une histoire de
choses sur leur chef bon parlons de
stephen rapp le on le voyait un peu plus
tôt dans le butin qui s'est rangée à
victoriaville il fait de rares visites
au québec quand même s'il vient pas très
souvent mais sa campagne de charme
auprès des québécois a l'air de
fonctionner michel il relie conservateur
remonte dans les sondages oui vraiment
un peu encore que celui qui lie place
est à 26 pour ça me laisse très
sceptique autour de 20 portes à fait
plausible c'est quand même la quatrième
fois en moins d'un an que monsieur
revient au québec alors ya un regain
d'intérêt pour le québec chez les
conservateurs c'est clair on le voyait
bien dans le reportage d'ailleurs
c'était bien expliqué à partir du moment
où on a une élection qui risque d'être
serrée ailleurs en particulier en
ontario la valeur le québec prend de la
valeur si on veut aller chercher je
trouve que 20 comptes et ça me paraît
très optimiste mais déjà son allant
chercher 10 12 ce serait plus du double
de la dernière fois et je pense qu'on va
mener une campagne très ciblée sur une
vingtaine de circonscriptions dont
celles là à richmond arthabaska
je pense le maire s est fait et un
candidat intéressant c'est la même chose
pour gérer la crise quand je suis à
québec pardon il s'en est pas cachée
aujourd'hui samedi je pense que ça me
semble acquis oui que de la même manière
que monsieur deltell fait semblant de
réfléchir encore mais j'ai l'impression
que là aussi c'est pas mal réglée alors
daniel à quoi tient cette remontée quand
même on avait pourtant il avait mis une
croix il faut faire attention quelques
sondages sur une courte période de temps
ça ne fait pas nécessairement un premier
temps et pense que les conservateurs
auraient peut-être de pavoiser trop
rapidement attendons de voir s'il ya une
tendance dans trois quatre cinq mois si
oui tant mieux sinon c'est une autre
histoire sauf que il est clair que
stephen harper à l'exception peut-être
de la nomination malheureuse de bave
nicholson aux affaires extérieures
quelqu'un qui ne parle pas français pas
un mot à l'exception de cette nomination
la il a en ce moment tous les bons
gestes la vitesse avec laquelle il a
rétabli le financement d'observatoire de
las vegas et qui est assez phénoménal le
stephen harper ne change jamais d'idées
aussi rapidement la vitesse avec
laquelle se déroule bien christian
paradis exactement à la chasse avec
laquelle cet après midi il a dit li
burqa il ya les peaux question si vous
posez un geste officiel on va dire
devant la cour suprême le tribunal au
tribunal pour contester la décision de
la cour fédérale il a en ce moment tous
les bons gestes la position dans les
sondages c'est intéressant ça permet
d'attirer des candidats intéressants
mais il faudra voir si ça dure les
québécois ont tellement diaboliser
stephen harper est ce qu'ils peuvent
tout à coup changé d'idée moi je me
donne un peu de temps avant de me
prononcer mais il éléments neufs quand
même le climat créé par charlie hebdo
bien sûr mais aussi vers les attentats
de l'an dernier a changé beaucoup de
perception chez les québécois y en pas
beaucoup plus les conservateurs mais il
commence à avoir plus part de
l'intégrisme et
il aurait dû calice mais en général la
loi et l'ordre ont pris du galon donc
d'achat pendant ce temps là bas c'est
lui qui occupe tout ce terrain sur le
terrain sécurité loi et ordre et tout ça
les deux autres partis on les entend pas
beaucoup là-dessus npd le
libero non on les entend pas et je pense
une des raisons c'est que ils savent pas
exactement où aller parce que l'opinion
publique est alimenté à chaque jour par
un autre histoire d'horreur de l'état
islamique qui force des enfants
maintenant à regarder des vidéos de jean
est de l'otage étant brûlée aviez fait
des choses semblables alors les
canadiens je pense l'appui pour les
mesures antiterroristes efforts on voit
des sondages il à 73% les québécois même
appuyé notre offensive en irak alors aux
autres artistes et difficile mais pour
monsieur harper je vais un jour juste
brièvement c'est un couteau à double
tranchant gagné beaucoup de terrain au
québec parce que si le [ __ ] est trop
faible au québec son vote aussi en
ontario là va tomber et si c'est que les
libéraux vont faire des guerres en
ontario alors pour les conservateurs
c'est difficile de régler ces deux
provinces là et garder la force de la
pda un niveau optimal on pourrait dire
et pendant cette campagne fédérale il
pourrait y avoir un nouveau joueur si
pierre karl péladeau est élu chef du
parti québécois ce que ça peut changer
la donne daniel écoutez
je sais pas honnêtement je devrais
savoir je ne sais pas écouter pierre
karl péladeau et cette course à la
direction du pq sa voix dans une seule
direction référendum d'indépendance les
québécois une fois péladeau élus tenons
pour acquis que ce sera lui on peut se
poser la question qui de stephen harper
justin trudeau thomas mulcair peut le
mieux nous défendre
s'il devait y avoir un autre référendum
est ce que stephen rapp est mieux placé
il faudra voir faudra voir aussi
l'impact pierre karl péladeau aura sur
le bloc québécois il a déjà dit que
reichmann michel dijoux et rock qui
n'était pas particulièrement en amour
avec le bloc québécois est ce que ça
pourrait inciter les militants péquistes
d'aller voter pour le bloc québécois si
oui ça change la donne ça nous donne de
ta quatre parties au québec mais tout ça
est encore
sujet de la fin michel ouais ce qu'ils
voient est intéressant c'est de voir
comment à l'extérieur du québec on va
percevoir sa à ce que monsieur peut par
exemple vont être perçu comme
le champion d'une ténacité normalement
c'est un fonds de commerce libéral cette
histoire là on peut dire que monsieur
trudeau l'enfant du pays serait mieux
placé pour convaincre les québécois de
voter non mais on peut dire aussi que
monsieur trudeau ou peut-être pas perçu
comme quelqu'un que la poigne assez
ferme pour gérer éventuellement une
crise que ça provoquerait est le plus
mal pris de tous je penserai monsieur
monsieur molière dont les électeurs une
bonne partie en tout cas sont
souverainistes et alors jouer l'huile le
matamore de l'unité nationale c'est
c'est plus délicat ça dépendra de la
question que les gens vont se poser
quand ils seront dans l'isoloir d'espoir
tâche à l'absolu mans et moi je me sens
rien la vie sur piles à doha date et je
trouvais très volatile sa performance
dans sa campagne je pense qu'il va
gagner mais on ne sait jamais ce qu'il
va dire ou avoir une mauvaise journée ou
une bonne journée alors la force qu'il
va apporter ans mais ça reste à voir la
peur que ça va avoir sur la carte
fédérale très bien toujours très
intéressant merci beaucoup à vous trois
ans on se retrouve la star ocean on va
voir